Kevin Spacey yes acquitted on all
non-sexual offense charges in London
trial this is a Reuters story Kevin
Spacey is acquitted from all nine with
the jury finding him not guilty by
majority after 12 hours and 26 minutes
of deliberation during the trial space
emotionally thanked
the jurors and stated I'm humbled by the
outcome today and expressed gratitude
for the to the for the jury's careful
examination of the evidence of the
evidence
Spacey face accusations of being a
sexual bully and aggressively groping
three men while he claimed he'd be
incident if they occurred were
consensual describing himself as
promiscuous and engaging in casual
indiscriminate sexual encounters the
accusations led to significant
professional consequences for the actor
in 2017 with his removal from TV drama
House of Cards and a movie all the money
in the world Vinnie what do you thought
well first of all acting wise you
already know Kevin Spacey usual suspect
House of Cards one of my favorite shows
ever and still still is he was found
guilty right that his lawyer said his
name is Patrick Gibbs he told the jury
verbatim and I quote it was not a crime
for his client to enjoy casual gay sex
because it's 2023 not 18 23 and the four
four victims of this said that he was
vile he was a sexual predator slippery
which I never heard anybody call
somebody slippery which is weird
atrocious despicable able and disgusting
and let's not forget everybody uh in
2019 back in the day three of his past
accusers died Ari Ben committed suicide
Linda Culkin hit by a car and another
John Doe which the cause of death was
unknown and then mind you he was accused
for groping Anthony Rapp who was 14
years old at the time uh Elton John Pat
you know how good it like this was in
London it helps when Elton John comes to
your side and speaks as a witness to the
jury I'm pretty sure that didn't help
anything but dude what's scary is and I
know people forgot back when one of
these guys committed suicide one of his
accusers
Kevin Spacey made a video during
Christmas that to me Basie said to
people because he says you kill them
with kindness he says dead and killed
him with kindness twice Rob can you show
this video so people could see how scary
and creepy this freaking guy is
a pretty good year you and I'm grateful
to have my health back
and in light of that I've made some
changes in my life and I'd like to
invite you to join me this is not a
movie no no it's not a movie and his
accuser just died committed suicide hash
my vote for
it's not that hard trust me watch the
next time someone does something you
don't like
you can go on the attack but you can
also hold your fire and do the
unexpected
you can
kill them with kindness are you are you
kidding me
Patrick by the way that's just a skit
yeah
that's a video that's a real that's not
a skit by the way
just to be clear let me say one thing
MasterCards he's speaking in a Southern
accent he's doing he's playing a
character here
he's doing Frank okay okay so there you
go guys guys time out I've he's doing it
he paid for this production he's
basically saying somebody just died that
said that he groped or gave them a
[__] and he made this video saying
you kill them with kindness if that's
not him saying if you f with me you're
going to die and he's smirking and he's
laughing that's the Hollywood Elite
Untouchable I said it two weeks ago he
knows he's gonna walk scot-free and
that's this is the protected Elite
Epstein perverted messing with 14 year
olds that we [__] just saying yeah
it's all good it's all good just like
what's his name Pat who is the actor uh
the one with the hoods with his wife was
crying about the kid that he molested Uh
Wood Woody Allen Woody Allen we let this
[__] go and he's gonna walk scot-free
and that's it bro that's scary and
that's disgusting about groping 14 year
old kids he also grow what's his name uh
who's the other actor
um the one that was uh there's a couple
things when you look at this here so
there's a couple things okay I I
subscribe to innocent till proven guilty
that's number one I do uh because for
for for us to go hardcore after him and
then when people say what about Tate
what about Tate what about tayden it's
like no this guy's for sure guilty but
no those guys are innocent I subscribe
to innocent until proven guilty period
now having said that do I think O.J
Simpson is innocent no I don't and
neither does anybody else in America if
you go right now pull up the poll what
percentage of Americans think O.J
Simpson killed uh uh you know Nicole
Brown and see what the percentage is and
you'll see what numbers come up uh a
recent poll on what percentage 71
percent think so okay and it keeps
increasing year after year after year
and today's even higher than that by the
way if you show the poll right the Civil
Trial he was found guilty right from the
goldense and Pat even him yeah but he
didn't do time he didn't go away no into
anything he was free there was an
emotional day when the announcement was
made riots were outside OJ's out right
and he'd go to Michael Jackson you know
I mean what's wrong with them having
underwears everywhere this is just very
friendly when they sleep in my bed I'm
like no bro there's nothing normal about
that and guess what nothing really
happened there with Michael Jackson okay
Michael didn't go to jail Michael didn't
do anything of course you know God Rest
the soul you know whether he's in heaven
or hell that's not on us that's on God
to decide that but the point is
this isn't the first time a powerful
Hollywood celebrity got away with
literally murder that can be said okay
100 yeah that can be said so that's the
part that you can defend for me if if
you were to ask somebody do you think he
did those things and we run a poll I
think probably most people are going to
say I believe he did how he got away
with it in London I don't know how the
courts are in London I don't know if
they're stricter I don't know if they're
more lenient I don't know if they're
anything else I don't even know if that
case can be opened in a different
country or in a different you know I
don't know any of that stuff I don't
know what's going to happen there but
yeah but when he had 14 year old a 14
year old actor said he groped me and
tried to rape me at what point do we say
okay enough is enough and the arrogance
to make that video is just like when OJ
you brought up OJ great point he wrote a
book called and didn't get published I
didn't do it but if I did this is how I
would have killed her yeah what the [__]
I'm sorry Pat what the OJ thing what
let's not complete OJ who no it doesn't
matter literally killed somebody no two
people no but it's weird whatever Kevin
space Vinnie I'm gonna ask you a
question you asked me too
yeah do you think he's guilty or do you
want Kevin Spacey to be guilty think
about it like I'll tell you you want him
to be good definitely not I told him I
told you I'm a huge fan of his work I've
been following him for all these years I
think he is because why would two 14
year olds kid Richard dreyfus's son was
another one like what are these kids we
don't believe kids no he's he looks by
the way and because people were like my
friend was like he's gay they're not
it's not even who gives a damn he's he
one of these accusers that was in London
said that while he was sleeping he took
off his pants I don't know how the guy
didn't wake up but he was trying to give
him a [__] when the guy was sleeping
and it's like bro it's sexual assault
and the line that I draw Pat and you
know this when it's to the kids when
it's a 14 year old kid and what your
lawyer's better than that kid and that's
what you get off no no no bro no no no
I'm sorry listen I mean they're off
limits but by the way if you watch the
Michael Jackson interviews there's
plenty of interviews when you're
watching you're like dude that that's
sick what you just said right now yeah
we're just we're just put yourself in
bed we're not doing anything it's just
innocent you know it's just kids it's
this it's dead like no and then and then
the the the what do you call it the mate
is like no there was always underwears
there with stains in the underwear in
the interview of the documentary and all
of some people coming out saying I can't
believe you said this and they forced
this guy to flip the script look there's
a lot of dark stuff that happens in
Hollywood that's for sure the story is
endless so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
oh